I feel like we're we're just one of the
best classes in a while top to bottom
it's not just like a one through ten
it's like everyone's good this is
definitely probably one of the more
known classes yeah just because how far
names travel nowadays with social media
we're kind of like the social media area
too era too I'm gonna start doing some
tick tocks nope some of those things
like when you're just bored away from
basketball kind of a little Escape just
to watch funny videos and stuff like if
you make that like distract you away
from the main thing then that's when it
comes to problem I feel like it's
positive if you just understand yeah it
can be both ways like if you make it
negative that's probably the worst thing
that social media can do for you that's
why I try to do it get on Tick Tock like
after I'm done with all my work and
stuff then I can mess around